SPEAKER 1: While big data
brings us valuable insights
and opportunities, it also
brings the responsibility
to ensure that data
is secure, meaning
that only the right data is
shared with the right people.
In today's episode of
"BigQuery Spotlight"
we're talking about how to
use Google Cloud's Identity
and Access Management
Service to define
which users can query
in your projects
and access your data sets.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
BigQuery's a fully
managed service.
That means it takes advantage
of Google's infrastructure
security.
Google secures its
infrastructure end
to end, from physical
security of its services
to stringent
operational practices.
But today's episode
is about the role
you play in keeping your
projects and data secure.
Specifically, how you
share project and data
set access with different
end users and groups
in your company.
The key to managing access
to your projects and data
is the Identity and Access
Management Service or IAM.
Cloud IAM allows you to
manage access control
by defining three things;
member, role and policy.
Meaning you specify who has
what access to which resource.
Let's take a closer
look at each of these.
First, the member,
or who has access.
You can define a
member in several ways.
One way is to identify end
users by their email address
if it's associated
with a Google account.
You can also set access
for a group of users
by using a Google Group, G
Suite domain, or Cloud Identity
domain as the member.
Sometimes it's not a person,
but an application or service
that needs access to
your BigQuery data.
In this case, you can
create a service account,
which is a special type
of Google account intended
to represent a non-human user.
When you create
service account, it
is assigned a
special address which
can be used as the member's
identity when defining access.
When I give a data set
access to any logged user,
there is a special
identifier called,
all authenticated
users, which you can
use as the member in this case.
This is exactly how we make
our BigQuery public data sets
available to all BigQuery users.
Once you have
defined the member,
you need to decide what
role to give that member.
A role includes a
set of permissions
that determines which
operations the member
is allowed to perform.
Cloud IAM provides
several predefined roles
that include a combination
of these permissions.
They include things
like the ability
to view or edit data
sets, and the ability
to run queries and
store data which
are billed to the project.
It is also possible to
create custom roles.
These allow you to bundle one
or more permissions into a role
to meet your specific needs.
You will have to manage your
custom role as new features,
permissions and services
are added to Google Cloud.
So for this reason, we recommend
sticking to predefined roles.
You can always assign more
than one predefined role
to a member.
Together, the
member and the role
make up the policy,
which is then
applied to a specific resource.
The policy could be attached
to a specific table,
data set, or the
GCP project itself.
At the project
level, permissions
apply actual current
and future data sets
that are part of the project.
Let's see how it works
in a specific scenario.
Suppose you're a retail
company with two groups of data
analysts.
The first group analyzes
your retail sales,
and the second analyzes
customer service requests.
These two types of data are
stored in separate data sets
within your project.
Both groups of analysts need
full access, read and write,
to the data set
that they work on
and access to run
queries on the project.
Let's head to the console
and set up the policies.
You'll start by giving the
sales analysts the BigQuery data
editor role for the
retail sales data set.
To set roles at
the data set level,
select the data
set from resources,
then click share data set
near the right-hand side
of the window.
On the data set
permissions tab, enter
the entity you want to add
into the Add Members text box.
For select a role, select
BigQuery data editor and click
Add.
Then click done.
Then follow the same steps
to give the customer service
analysts the BigQuery data
editor role for the customer
service data set.
You'll notice we're using
Google groups to grant roles.
Google groups are
a convenient way
to create a policy for
collection of users.
You can grant and change access
for a whole group at once,
instead of individual
users one at a time.
Then you can easily add
or remove members directly
from the Google Group itself.
Giving the analyst the data
editor role at the data set
level gives them the ability
to access all the tables
within that particular
data set, but it does not
give them the permission
to actually run
queries billed to that project.
For that, they must be granted
the project level role called,
BigQuery user.
To grant roles at
the project level,
you'll need to head to
the navigation window.
Hover over IAM in admin and
then click to select IAM.
At the top of the
screen, click add.
In the new members
box, enter both email
addresses to represent
your analyst groups.
Select the BigQuery user
role and click Save.
Now your two teams are ready and
equipped to analyze their data
securely.
If you want to learn
more about BigQuery,
check out the rest
of our playlist.
And don't forget to
subscribe to our channel
on YouTube for
other great content.
Look out for our next episode
of "BigQuery Spotlight"
and remember, stay curious.
[MUSIC PLAYING]